humans are weird animals
we're terrified of ghosts monsters
snakes spiders
all kinds of other things both real and
imagined and that's normal
it's healthy even so why do we actually
enjoy being afraid
by experiencing these things on purpose
and there's a science behind fear that
explains why being frightened can be fun
at least for some people let's find out
why
[Music]
welcome to the y files where cool nerds
like us laugh and learn
do you like to be afraid i hope so
because at some point in this video
i'm going to try to scare the crap out
of you no warning nothing
well if i warn you it won't be as scary
oh i don't like this one bit
do you want me to stop nope see enjoying
fear seems like a contradiction
but horror movies are a billion dollar
business and throw in horror tv and
horror gaming
that's billions more halloween spending
is about 8 billion a year and roller
coasters
the scarier the ride the longer the line
so we're definitely fascinated by being
afraid
but why well we're gonna cover five
reasons but first let's try to
understand what fear
actually is is it a certain heart rate
for a period of time or sweaty palms or
dilated pupils
hyperventilating well these are really
just our reactions to fear
according to the oxford english
dictionary fear is defined as the
emotion of pain or uneasiness
caused by a sense of impending danger or
by the prospect of some possible
evil so fear is an emotion that you feel
when you sense danger
fine and if you take a look at the
things you're most afraid of
you realize that they could pose some
danger to you in one way or another now
of course every person is different with
their own set of fears
our unique and sometimes common fears
are driven by our personality as well as
the experiences we've had in our lives
however not all fear is rational like
why everyone isn't afraid of clowns is
beyond me
you have issues true we have a video
coming up on weird phobias so
hit all the buttons to be notified
shameless plunge
a number of psychologists and
neuroscientists have tried to figure out
the answer
to why people like to be afraid let's
get into the five reasons
reason number one safety net the safety
net is when we intentionally put
ourselves into potentially frightening
situations
while simultaneously understanding
there's no real danger
such as a haunted house or watching a
scary movie what did you say
or maybe standing on top of a tall
building or walking over a bridge of
glass
despite being terrified our brains do
realize that we're actually safe
and because we're not in any real danger
we're able to enjoy these experiences
well some of us are on the other hand if
we were to have similar experiences
without knowing there was a safety net
our reactions would be very different we
are not going to enjoy those situations
at all and we would immediately go into
fight or flight mode
we would literally be in a survival
situation and do anything
possible to ensure our safety and as you
would expect
this is not the case with controlled
fearful experiences
so what causes the actual feeling of
pleasure when we put ourselves through
controlled fear i can't control their
fear
only my own
the flood dr margie kerr spent 10 years
investigating fear
her research showed that when people
experience fear and momentarily
experience the fight-or-flight response
there's a cascade of chemicals released
into our brain
these chemicals are associated with the
threat response has a movie ever made
you jump or scream and that immediately
after you started laughing
that's the flood in action we experience
a rush of adrenaline
and a release of endorphins and dopamine
the biochemical rush can result in a
sense of euphoria
and heightened awareness then when we
remember that we're safe
the experience of fear quickly subsides
and we're left with a gratifying sense
of relief
and subsequent well-being and that ebb
and flow of neurotransmitters
feels really good to some people and
when our metabolism increases so quickly
we put all our energy and focus on the
moment where we can just take a break
and enjoy being fully present and primal
you know when you're terrified
there's no time for anxious rumination
about the future
or why your soon-to-be-ex hasn't texted
you back or how many subscribers you
have
there's no thinking about past events or
regrets or
how many subscribers you have don't
obsess sorry the human body's fear
response is very well designed and
highly evolved
and it needs to be if you think about it
any cave people who are really chill and
like not afraid of anything evolution
was not kind to them
they're not here because they were
saber-toothed tiger food
but the cave people who had the good
sense to run away from danger
and cower back in their caves well
that's us
no never apologize for an effective kill
circle so if we're in a situation where
we know we're safe like a haunted house
or scary movie or a scary ride we can
hijack the fear response
and actually enjoy it it's sort of a way
to hack your brain chemistry
the chemical signatures of happiness and
excitement are similar to those of when
we're scared it's just
different context
that is another reason why we love being
afraid
is self-satisfaction and a sense of
achievement now i'm sure you've
experienced this
how did you feel after doing something
that you were really afraid of
or after pushing yourself to do
something difficult didn't it
feel good and give you a sense of power
and a feeling of accomplishment
it's a similar sense of accomplishment
you experience after killing a boss in a
video game
or skydiving for the first time enduring
a stressful activity
and then purposely putting ourselves
through them gives us a russia dopamine
and our brain tells us that we can do
things we're afraid of and we can push
ourselves beyond our limits
because we can no that was inspirational
close bonding develops with the people
that are present with us
sharing a scary experience and if you
think about it doing frightening things
is much more fun
when you're with friends or family i
mean when we go as a group into a
haunted house
we're taking on challenges together and
in doing so we create stronger bonds
stronger memories and feelings of
closeness if you watch people coming out
of a scary ride or
getting beers after a day of skydiving
you'll see a lot of hugs and high fives
and everyone's in a good mood
this burst of emotion is due to raised
oxytocin levels
and during the time we're doing these
activities our bodies and minds are in a
heightened state of emotion
energy focus and consciousness and
everyone present is experiencing the
same feelings
so we scream laugh hold each other's
hands run
sometimes even cry when we experience
these things while having a great time
it helps us bond with each other these
intense emotional experiences help us
create
unforgettable memories don't you
remember the times you were really
frightened but everything worked out
okay i mean we all do
those become memories that we cherish
for our entire lives
that's why we seek them out curiosity
people are curious about the dark side
of humanity especially people who watch
this channel
i mean whether it's true crime or ghosts
or zombies or an alien invasion
the fear of the unknown is one of the
most instinctive fears we have
for the most part we like our worlds to
make sense we like life wrapped up in a
nice neat little package
our world is just easier to engage with
when things make sense
to us if we look at our daily lives
they're pretty predictable right
we have our set of routines we know what
to do what to expect
we go to work or school we come home
maybe watch tv
hang out with friends and then go to bed
and just like groundhog day we repeat
that routine
over and over again without much
deviation we rarely experience
anything unexpected even if we do
something that's not part of our routine
we're still familiar with the
consequences we know how everyday things
work
and we know what happens as a result of
everyday actions even if they vary a
little bit
so when we put ourselves through
frightening experiences like watching a
horror movie or playing a scary game
there's an element of surprise every
twist turn and scare that comes our way
surprises us
and before we fully grasp the situation
there's anticipation for war
the thrill and excitement that we feel
is unlike anything we experience
on a typical day our routine is
disrupted
and we can't help but seek out novel
experiences that depart from our
everyday routines
that makes a lot of sense but not
everybody enjoys being afraid
every brain experiences fear and anxiety
differently and you may be more
vulnerable depending on how your brain
is shaped
your amygdala the part of your brain
connected to and just behind the
prefrontal cortex
is in charge of what makes you afraid
and how you choose to express it now
people who suffer from anxiety already
have prefrontal cortexes that look
a little different than other folks and
different types of anxiety disorders
will restructure brains differently for
example
people with panic disorders and ptsd
have an underactive prefrontal cortex
but those with worry-based anxiety like
ocd and generalized anxiety disorder
usually have an overactive prefrontal
cortex people who enjoy
fear may have a different number of
autoreceptors than others
now autoreceptors are presynaptic nerve
cells that control how much dopamine and
other neurotransmitters are released in
your brain
people with fewer dopamine autoreceptors
may get more dopamine from a scare
animals love dopamine and humans are no
different so those with few dopamine
receptors
need more of the chemical in order to
feel that sense of satisfaction and
accomplishment
and because they have fewer dopamine
receptors they lack the ability to put
on the brakes in a dangerous situation
that's what leads to an addiction to
thrilling situations these are your
typical adrenaline junkies
but it's not really the adrenaline they
crave it's the dopamine
we also perceive fear differently based
on our life experiences
people who prefer rom-coms or comedy
over horror
that's probably because their
personality and their temperament are
different than
those people that do like it now if
you've had bad experiences with a
haunted house or a horror movie
you're more likely to associate all
things fun scary with
feeling bad or if you were never exposed
to fun
scary as a child maybe your parents
weren't into horror movies or whatever
you don't really have a frame of
reference for why or how something scary
could be
fun people like this don't even really
understand how being frightened could
possibly be enjoyable
i'm one of those people now regardless
of which personality type you are
there's no escaping fear it's as natural
as breathing but learning more about why
you feel fear and what triggers you have
can help you figure out how better to
face your fears and not let them control
you
and that's a pretty good reason to every
once in a while get out of your comfort
zone
push yourself and just have the
scared out of you thanks for hanging out
with us today my name is aj that's
hecklefish
this has been the y-files do you enjoy
being afraid what scary things do you
find fun let us know in the comments
maybe we'll do a video about it now if
you had fun or learned anything today do
us a favor please like subscribe
comment and share i hate to give you
homework but you know
we're holding up our end until next time
be safe be kind
and know that you are appreciated
you can't get rid of fear it's like
mother nature
you can't beat her out runner but he can
get through it
you can find out what you're made of
you